hi I'm Erik Bosse and our review of epic
game of Thrones moments leads us to the
time this series really showed us it's
balls whoa that's obviously not what I
meant get out of here Hodor hold the
towel next time of course I'm referring
to the shocking death of Eddard Stark
the main protagonist of season one and
yet another unceremonious death of a
Sean Bean character
and no I do not consider this as spoiler
anymore guys by now the fact that Ned
Stark dies the season one is as well
known as a shows existence so don't
whine in the comments that I spoiled you
you're lying you already knew that's it
I will be getting into some stuff that
happens later in the series so I guess
the spoiler warning for that stuff
seeing as this is the most pivotal
moment of the entire series let's
revisit this scene and analyze
everything that makes it a great moment
of television the interesting miscible
details in the scene but also the cool
ways the episodes prior foreshadowed it
and its legacy to the series from the
show's perspective why did Ned Stark
deserve to die the decision to kill off
the main character so early it's pretty
unprecedented for television it's one of
the reasons the game of Thrones book was
so difficult to adapt to screen it's
just so much harder to get viewers
invested in a character then too cruelly
snatch that character away from them
unlike in a book where you kind of feel
committed to the pot this heavy thing
with TV show you couldn't just stop
watching a lot of people do that when TV
shows kill off beloved characters just
that's the walking dead actually fun
fact the original pilot of ABC's lost
plan to kill off leading dude Jack
Shephard by the end of the first episode
but JJ Abrams ended up caving when they
realized that fans would be attached to
him so chopping off Sean beans head
really only worked because Game of
Thrones earned it by setting it up with
a sense of inevitability establishing
itself as a world where this character
needed to die Ned's execution was
foreshadowed even in episode 1 when he
executes sad Azura from the Nights Watch
this scene is shown from the point of
view of his son bran as the father
leaves him with a critical lesson but do
you understand why I had to kill him
Oh where's the old way the man who
passes the sentence should swing the
sword in this moment Ned was
establishing his old traditional
worldview of what makes a justified
killing his own death leader is a mirror
opposite of this execution scene but
I'll come back to that everything of
course changes for Ned when he decides
to enter this game of Thrones by joining
Robert as his hand in episode 2 in the
Kings Road the conflict between Joffrey
and Arya leads Ned to have to unjustly
put down lady Sansa's dire wolf his
simple honorable understanding of
justice has been eroded the way the wolf
becomes asked
goat for the petty conflicts between the
families Ned will later serve as a
scapegoat to bleed for the sins of all
of these characters and I know it might
have sounded a bit harsh when I earlier
suggested Ned Stark deserved to die but
now looking back at his decisions he
acted so naively and stupid that it's
hard to see how he ever could have
lasted in the world of Game of Thrones
as we know it today from the moment Ned
arrived at King's Landing he began
digging his own grave
he immediately threatens or at least
antagonizes Jaime Lannister Petyr
Baelish Varys pycelle
he lets Littlefinger turn him against
Tyrion Lannister and gets himself into a
fight with the deadliest family in the
south he squanders his own household
guard the only people there to protect
him sending them to help the city watch
police the city and he wastes even more
of them and search for Arya when she
goes missing he doesn't at all hide his
investigation into Robert's bastards and
Joffrey's truth lineage then with Robert
on his deathbed he completely shows his
hand to Cersei leading her to declare
this memorable promise when you play the
game of Thrones you win or you die right
after this he refuses to ally himself
with Renly proclaiming that Stannis is
the rightful heir after Robert and then
he wouldn't want to harm Circe's
children you later defenses to Varys as
the madness of mercy dumbest of all he
placed all of his trust on Littlefinger
even though little vicar told him this
is trusting me was the wisest thing
you've done since you've climbed off
your horse looking back we should have
all been surprised with Littlefinger and
the City Watch suddenly turned on the
Starks that said rewatching the moments
between his arrest in his execution the
show does a remarkable job keeping us in
suspense they do just enough to make us
believe that Stark has a chance to
survive so let's reexamine this moment
at Baylor when Ned passes his daughter
Sansa she wears this grave little smile
the hope of a child who thinks she has
successfully spared her father and as
Arya watches in horror from the base of
the Baylor statue they include this shot
of her gripping needle and for a second
we're all like yeah this could totally
be like the end of Pirates of the
Caribbean when Orlando Bloom throws that
sword for Jack Sparrow to stand on to
keep himself hanging this is gonna be
great
on so many levels this trial is
completely unjust for Ned Stark not just
for the obvious reasons that he wasn't a
traitor he was following Robert's will
and exposing the Lannisters lie the
setting is
completely wrong for him the Sept of
Baelor worships the seventh that Ned is
a northerner doesn't really pray to his
guys are the old gods and these new gods
were never really gonna shown any mercy
or justice actually in a perverse irony
the sword that sir Ellen uses to behead
him is ice Stark's ancient family
Valyrian steel sword the same one we saw
him used in the first episode now in the
seconds before it swings down you can
barely make out Ned whispering something
to himself now it's safe to assume he's
whispering a prayer to his old gods lip
readers have actually tried to make out
what Sean Bean was saying here some have
interpreted I kept my promise
thinking he was referencing his promise
to his sister Lyanna about Jon Snow
others have made out father forgive me
closest answer we have comes from the
episode's translation into other
languages which gives us a subtitle
showing protect my family and that
ultimately is Ned Stark's final act here
the episode gets its title from Ned's
message to urine as a passes him Baelor
Ned doesn't want Arya to see him like
this unlike with bran whom he did want
to watch the past execution Ned doesn't
want Arya to see this execution not just
to spare her innocence but because it's
unjust he fears it will corrupt her
respect for justice allow her to see
killing used in a more sadistic way and
even though she doesn't actually see it
this traumatic injustice does lead Arya
down a very dark path of course we also
have to credit the amazing sound design
of this whole sequence the way the jeers
of the crowd fade away for Ned its we
focus only on his breathing
but also the clanging of the bells as
REO walks up to a baler
now I pointed this out before but you
can hear those same bells in the
background every time Aria shares a
scene with their father in season 1 I
open the door all of those moments were
foreshadowing this final moment between
the two characters but I think what I
love the most about rewatching the scene
is the weight everyone goes apeshit when
Joffrey gives the order Santa of course
loses it various runs over to plead with
the boy king pycelle looks totally
shocked
Cersei grabs Joffrey's arms snapping at
him to reconsider doing her best to
maintain composure as her psycho son
burns a world down only Littlefinger
looks smug here this is exactly the
chaos he needs to climb the ladder it's
as if all these characters are suddenly
realizing that this game they've been
playing is way more unpredictable than
they ever could have imagined they're
terrified that they're now living in a
world where anyone including themselves
and died and that leads us to the deeper
meaning of Ned Stark's death now sure we
can debate whether Ned Stark deserved to
die he was certainly the most noble and
admirable character we saw in this
series but those qualities are precisely
why George RR Martin's book in this
series needed to abruptly remove him
from this narrative Game of Thrones is
not Lord of the Rings it's not a world
where decency thrives and gets rewarded
so Eddard Stark was never meant to be a
survivor he was designed from the start
as a tragic scapegoat that would
eventually break our hearts and teach us
a terrifying lesson about Game of
Thrones his death opened up a world
where no one is truly safe well until
like season six
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but for most of the other characters
throughout this series those
unprecedented ly high stakes means Ned
Stark's death was totally deserved but a
question for you guys do you think Ned
Stark might have been morally deserving
of his death like how admirable was he
really I guess an argument could be made
that Stark was paying a debt to the
realm for helping the heartbroken drunk
Robert Baratheon steal the Iron Throne
from the dynasty that held it by right
for a thousand years and then leave it
to no trueborn heirs descending Westeros
into chaos I guess sure the Mad King was
a true [ __ ] and he needed to go or
did he now we're all clamoring for the
mad Kings grandkids to rule so crap I
got to rethink everything I want to know
your thoughts down below in the comments
I also want to thank you guys for
watching these analyses at the top Game
of Thrones moments and I know some of
you really wanted me to stick to the
episode by episode breakdowns that we
were doing I truly loved doing those two
but honestly 20-minute breakdowns of
barely memorable episodes from old
seasons of TV quickly became the most
expensive project for this channel and
unfortunately not enough people were
tuning in to make it work for us
economically considering all the other
stuff we have to cover too
fortunately switching to covering these
specific moments allowed me to kind of
pick my battles literally and go as deep
into those moments as I really want to
so hopefully you're enjoying these that
said that doesn't mean we've abandoned
the episode by episode re-watch plan
that's still something we're thinking
about ways to get to you guys and we're
open to whatever ideas you have feel
free to tweet me at da boss or follow
new rockstars on Twitter at new
rockstars for updates on our videos and
you can like this video and subscribe to
directors for all of our Game of Thrones
analysis and one way that you can get
involved and helping us decide what kind
of content to do is to contribute to us
on patreon a big thanks of course to all
of our donors especially Allen Fleming
thanks for watching guys bye